[Musique]
jean marc jancovici bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur marianne tv alors plutôt que de
faire une présentation aux lecteurs de
votre parcours
j'aurai je préférerais que ce soit vous
qu'il fasse il alors
jean marc jancovici qui et nous on va si
vite et est ce qui concerne ma vie
professionnelle
ça change identiques être jardinier oui
et alors donc j'ai quatre casquettes
dans ma vie professionnelle qui sont en
décroissance de co dirigé une société
qui s'appelle carbone 4 et qui
s'intéresse ou qu'ils essayent
d'intéresser les entreprises plus
exactement à la question de l'énergie et
du climat et à la façon de relever les
défis qui sont devant nous j'ai une
deuxième activité qui est d'avoir fondé
de présider une association qui
s'appelle de shit project et qui milite
en gros pour la décarbonation de
l'économie j'ai une troisième casquette
qui est d'enseigner
je suis professeur à mines paristech je
suis régulièrement des interventions qui
ressemble un peu à ce que je fais en
cours mais en plus courts pardon pour la
répétition dans d'autres établissements
d'enseignement et puis j'ai une dernière
casquette qui l'a dit un an et demi qui
est de faire partie du haut conseil pour
le climat qui est une instance qui a été
créée au qui imite un peu ce qu'ont fait
les anglais il ya beaucoup plus
longtemps avec un instant s'appelle le
climate change committee et qui
surveille on va dire la trajectoire des
missions gaz à effet serre de la france
en expliquant où nous en sommes et ce
qu'on pourrait éventuellement essayer de
faire pour que sérieux sur ce point vous
avez acquis une très grande audience et
une très grande légitimité sur des
questions qui sont absolument
essentielles et qui pourtant passe très
souvent en dessous des regards des
médias classiques c'est les questions
d'énergie
alors quand on regarde l'histoire de
l'humanité l'énergie est au coeur
d'absolument toutes les révolutions qui
ont bouleversé la vie des hommes c'est
au coeur de l'organisation des sociétés
c'est au coeur aussi des questions
géopolitiques
comment expliquez vous que ce sujet ne
soit pas celui qui aujourd'hui anime nos
débats et qui soit celui qui mobilise
j'allais dire le débat démocratique
alors excellente question et si je suis
un peu taquin voulait plus la réponse
que moi donc c'est plutôt à vous qu'on
devrait poser la question moi j'ai
quelques hypothèses la première
hypothèse c'est que l'énergie c'est un
sujet qui est d'abord technique physique
ils sont peu l'essentiel des
journalistes ont fait des études
littéraires donc s'ils ne sont pas
confrontés à ce sujet là dans le cadre
de leur métier avec la nécessité
d'apprendre
ensuite de quoi il retourne qui sont un
peu perdus et donc
il aime pas trop où les sujets sur
lesquels ils sont un peu perdus il ya un
deuxième élément qui explique ça c'est
que c'est compliqué à vulgariser dans
des temps très courts sais pas où je
vais apprendre que le média aujourd'hui
c'est un instrument du temps court faute
ourdir très très vite très donc c'est
pas un sujet qui est commode pour la
troisième
troisième élément c'est que dans ce
domaine là aujourd'hui il ya à la fois
des explications qu'on peut apporter
alors ça on pourrait considérer à la
rigueur que c'est du domaine des médias
mais les médias français sont
globalement mauvais prolongement pour la
raison que j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
sur tout ce qui est vulgarisation
scientifique
de façon globale concerne pas que
l'énergie on est par exemple très très
loin derrière les anglais qui sont bien
meilleurs que nous sur ce sujet donc la
rubrique science est toujours une
rubrique un peu croupion quand il y en a
eu une à une fois sur deux elle donne
dans un sensationnalisme techno
futuriste qui n'est pas l'explication de
la manière dont marche le monde mais à
regarder comme ça va être merveilleux
d'avoir des gadgets qui va faire j'sais
pas quoi donc le donc donc il ya une
difficulté à expliquer d'une façon
générale et en plus son domaine de
l'énergie et du changement climatique il
faut expliquer les mauvaises nouvelles
or les médias n'aiment pas les mauvaises
nouvelles parce que les médias ont
besoin d'une audience à cause de leurs
recettes publicitaires
et quand c'est des médias de service
public à cause du fait qu' il imite les
autres et que même le ministre en charge
de la culture et de la communication
pense que l'audience de radio france est
un bon indicateur de la performance de
radio france est habituellement une
explication plutôt que les médias
adorent les mauvaises nouvelles ne parle
que de ce qui ne va pas et qui
culpabilise l'audience voilà c'est
orientations de la corée du nord la
question du changement climatique et de
l'énergie si on veut s'attaquer
sérieusement et la question de la mise
au régime
et là on est on devient totalement
schizophrène c'est à dire que vous
pouvez pas juste et derrière une page de
pub qui va vous faire vous dire acheter
ceux ci acheter cela une explication qui
vous dit surtout ne fait pas bon et j'ai
des exemples de première main un certain
nombre oui il ya des régies
publicitaires qui sont intervenus auprès
de rédaction en disant oh mais attendez
vous n'avez pas commencer à parler de ce
genre de sujet donc ça c'est un
troisième élément qui voit là et enfin
le dernier élément c'est que les médias
adorent les accroche c'est à dire des
choses qui pioche dans l'actualité
l'explication du monde ne pioche dans
aucune actualité particulière sauf s'il
ya des raisons d'en par exemple quand il
ya de la convention climat tous les ans
alors là on peut en parler quand il ya
un ministre qui prend une décision on
peut en parler mais au moment où il va
prendre la décision le ou la ministre
en général on va parler des décisions va
pas parler du problème donc il ya un
défaut d'explications récurrent sur ce
sujet l'art depuis que je m'intéresse à
la question j'avais essayé d'apporter ma
modeste pierre au contournement de cette
difficulté en créant avec un copain
journaliste ya maintenant une quinzaine
d'années une école divers pour rédacteur
en chef qui s'appelle les entretiens de
combloux maintenant si on n'y a pas
invités du reste on a dû essayer ou ont
peut-être qu'on a essayé et on a assez
peu de succès avec ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler les journalistes vedettes dont
qu'ils aiment pas retourner à l'école
donc c'est à vous qu'il faudrait poser
la question encore une fois c'est
pourquoi mais je partage je partage vos
amis c'était qu'on le fait est qu'au
donc on a essayé de faire ça et alors
donc on a fêté trois jeux ces trois
jours de séminaire où on mélange
ba entre 20 et 30 journalistes avec des
experts et l'idée c'est pas du tout de
leur dire il faut être pour ceux ci où
il faut être pour contre cela l'idée
c'est de leur dire on va vous expliquer
le problème à traiter
donc c'est juste ça comment faire on va
vous expliquer de quoi il retourne quand
on parle d'énergie
de quoi il retourne quand on parle de
changement climatique on va vous donner
les bases du débat
en espérant que derrière justement vous
serez capable d'organiser le débat d'une
façon telle que ça ramène de la valeur
ajoutée à la collectivité
alors on a lancé ça il ya 15 ans
l'événement lui-même marche bien c'est à
dire qu'on a des gens qui ont envie de
venir
la façon dont sa structure l'évolution
derrière des médias sur ce sujet là
c'était difficile à non mais voilà c'est
très difficile à apprécier
j'avais je ne saurais le jour où je
mourrai si ça a joué un rôle totalement
nul ou si ça a joué un petit rôle dans
leur ensemble pour en rester à la
question du traitement journalistique
des sujets liés à l'énergie dont tout de
suite la question du nucléaire passera
sujet de plus long terme après je sais
que vous êtes né mais pas toujours la
façon dont les médias traitent cette
question vous même parfois ça vous
embête un peu de la traiter mais mettons
les pieds dans le plat pourquoi est ce
que les journalistes vous en parlez ont
du mal avec le nucléaire paris de
l'énergie en général mais sur la
question du nucléaire plus
particulièrement je ne sais que les
écolos ce que vous appelez contenir les
écolos entre institutionnels ont du mal
avec cette question et
on fait un fétichisme inversé c'est à
dire que surtout pas dire que le
nucléaire pourraient nous aider à avoir
ce parachute ventrale dont vous parlez
pour avoir une consommation énergétique
moins carboné alors très simplement
pourquoi est ce que les médias et les
politiques ont du mal avec ce sujet du
nucléaire eon
alors là aussi je réprouve et m je ne
peut que tenter des hypothèses une
première hypothèse c'est que le
nucléaire est un sujet technique donc
ils rentrent dans le lot générale de ce
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure avec des
sujets techniques qui sont pas très bien
traité dans tous les sujets techniques
la presse a globalement tendance en
france à confondre les faits les
opinions exactement à mélanger les deux
moi je me rappelle d'un certain nombre
de journalistes qui l'ont interrogé don
pour ne pas le nommer avec elf au monde
qui m'avait interrogé une demi-heure sur
tout un tas de sujet qui a retenu une
petite phrase sur le nucléaire dont je
parlais une fois mais pas deux et c'est
trés donc c'est un exemple typique de
quelqu'un qui mélange les faits les
opinions et qui a un agenda personnel
qui ne vous dis pas donc c'est voilà
donc ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est classique dans la presse
française
il ya un deuxième élément que je peux
rajouter à ça alors tout ça c'est un
empilement d'hypothèses et le nucléaire
ça fait référence à quelque chose qui ne
se voit pas radioactivité ne se voit pas
et on a tous tendance tous autant que
nous sommes des êtres humains à avoir
plus peur de ce qu'on ne comprend pas
que de se comprendre
c'est comme ça c'est normal si vous
lisez les neurobiologistes ils vous
expliqueront que c'est tout à fait
normal que ça fonctionne comme ça et on
a plus tendres on a tendance à avoir
plus peur des choses qui sont lointaines
que des choses qui sont proches
il n'y a pas longtemps j'ai donné une
interview un de vos confrères de la
libre belgique pour ne pas les nommer où
j'ai expliqué que les français avaient
plus peur des centrales nucléaires que
des piscines
alors que les piscines tue beaucoup plus
chaque année que les centrales
nucléaires si vous avez un enfant de
deux ans je peux vous assurer laissez-le
approché d'une centrale nucléaire avec
beaucoup moins d'appréhension qu'il faut
le laisser s'approcher d'une piscine
donc il ya un
on est aussi fait de telle sorte que ce
qui est loin nous fait toujours plus
peur que ce qui est prêt il ya beaucoup
de fumeurs qui ont très peur du
changement climatique comme ça que la
cigarette est beaucoup plus proche des
emmerdements pour eux il ya un troisième
élément après alors là qui à mon avis
est propre aux médias de service public
dans ce pays c'est que les journalistes
aiment clamé leur indépendance
même s'ils sont plus indépendants que
moi puisque comme je le disais tout à
l'heure ils sont dépendants de la régie
publicitaire de leurs médias il se
déporte sur dû prendre plein de trucs
mais quand même il aime bien dire qu'ils
sont indépendants
donc le quand vous êtes dans un média de
service public
la meilleure manière de prouver que vous
êtes indépendant de la main qui vous
nourrit c'est dire du mal de tout ce que
fait l'état donc vous remarquerez que
les médias de service public adore dire
du mal des flics des juges de
l'éducation nationale etc
et comme le nucléaire est une industrie
d'état le nucléaire passe dans la barque
et donc on dit du mal du nucléaire je
pense qu'il ya aussi ce resort lara qui
est assez fortement à l'oeuvre dans dans
la sphère donc c'est ça j'ai envie de
dire il ya ça dans les éléments
explicatifs a pris un ado qui viennent
se rajouter également on a un voisin qui
est notre allié européen historique
l'allemagne qui est très anti nucléaire
l'a probablement pour des raisons
beaucoup plus géopolitique comme vous le
savez après la seconde guerre mondiale
l'allemagne terrain d'occupation a dû
accepter alors que c'était quand même
une puissance économique majeure et ça
fait toujours du reste en europe a dû
accepter l'humiliation d'avoir des têtes
nucléaires sur son sol pointé vers
l'urss est pointée pour partie vers
leurs frères c'est à dire l'allemagne de
l'est
donc je pense que dans le mélange
nucléaire civil
il ya un sentiment qui est beaucoup plus
fort qu'en france qui s'est développée
et j'ai envie de dire dans le dialogue
franco-allemand sarah problement déteint
sur ce qui se passe chez nous aussi
voilà donc c'est tout un tas de raisons
conjoncturelles qu'on peut empiler les
veaux chinoise unes sur les autres et
fukushima n'a pas été un déclencheur
fukushima est un révélateur beaucoup
plus qu'un qu'un déclencheur j'ai fonds
climat juste pour rire là dessus est
très révélateur de ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure sur le service public
moi j'ai entendu sur france info que
fukushima avait fait vingt mille morts
ces pitchouns amis café famille mort
c'est fukushima alors que dont les
nations unies disent que ça n'a pas fait
un seul alors que oui c'était aussi le
fait que le nucléaire c'est
c'est une filière industrielle et qu' il
ya un impensé dans beaucoup de médias
français c'est la question de la mise en
valeur des filières industrielles en
france
je pense que c'est là aussi ça a été
totalement abandonné ses terres que
beaucoup de médias ont tout simplement
acheté le discours des années 80 90 sur
le fait que l'industrie était quelque
chose de sale dont il ne fallait pas
s'occuper parce que de toute façon
c'était bien mieux si on le faisait
ailleurs et qu'en revanche on allait
faire du service parce que et de la
banque parce que ça c'était moderne et
que ça c'était le possible je pense que
c'est possible
cela étant on ne constate pas il
n'existe pas par exemple de mouvement
sortir de la chimie on a une association
sortir du nucléaire en france on n'a pas
à se sortir de là chili alors que la
chimie tue beaucoup plus dans le monde
est beaucoup plus sage globalement que
nucléaire donc oui ça je suis d'accord
je pense que la chimie sa chanson je
viens depuis rouen et lubrizol on va pas
implanter une industrie chimique en
france sont posées c'est bien plus de
mal à implanter quoi que ce soit mais
pour pour le pour le fait que le
nucléaire soit une filière industrielle
alors là je suis sûr par contre que ça
joue sur un élément qui peut paraître
étonnant dans la perception des français
qui est que les plus les personnes les
plus sensibles à l'environnement sont
aussi paradoxalement les plus anti
nucléaire et alors là pour le coup mon
explication là je pense avoir les idées
assez claires
en fait les gens qui sont pour le
nucléaire sont plus largement pro tecno
pro industrie pro machin et ces gens là
globalement de façon assez logique sont
moins soucieux de la chose
environnementale et à linverse les gens
qui sont soucieux de la chose
environnementale voit tout ce qui est
avancé techno productives comme quelque
chose de pas terrible et le nucléaire
rentrer dans cette
c'est tout le paradoxe dans vos
positions et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est de croiser la question
on va dire de la décroissance avec la
question d'une réflexion sur une filière
qui en est faite une filière
technologique industriel qu'est le
nucléaire
le problème est que le nucléaire
évidemment n'est pas sans conséquence
sur l'environnement quand on voit les
réflexions qui a eu sur ben hur et sur
l'enfouissement des déchets des déchets
c'est absolument passionnant de se dire
qu'il ya des gens qui sont chargés de
réfléchir à la façon dont on va indiquer
dans mille dans dix mille ans comment on
saura qu'il y a des déchets enfouis là
on oublie évidemment que tout l'enjeu
c'est celui de la recherche la question
en fait elle n'est pas seulement là on
est de parler des médias et c'est vrai
que c'est très important dans la
question c'est celle aussi du politique
c'est à dire de la capacité à se
projeter à long terme et à réfléchir à
la société que nous voulons c'est à dire
avec quelle énergie
c'est à dire organisés à travers une
recherche qui va permettre d'améliorer
cette énergie tout ça n'a pas été fait
c'est peut-être là aussi le drame
il ya des choses qui sont faites alors
la réflexion de long terme elle est
enfin ou l'absence de réflexion à long
terme elle est propre à l'ensemble des
démocraties
il faut revenir aux bons auteurs qui
vous expliqueront que c'est tout à fait
normal que la démocratie est un système
court termiste
je sais je sais messieurs les
journalistes c'est il ya moyen de penser
le particulier de sanaa je pense que la
part construction la démocratie est un
système court termiste est du reste on
voit bien que dans les démocraties
occidentales à mesure que le temps passe
les échéances se raccourcissent tenter
de vous demander quelle est
l'alternative
je n'ai pas encore trouvé d'abord je
pense qu'il faut se garder de cette
tradition française de concevoir le
système idéal sans se poser la question
de savoir comment on doit donc en fait
moi j'ai plus tendance à raisonner à
l'envers c'est à dire compte tenu des
choix qui sont à d'autres mains là
demain matin quel est le moins mauvais
c'est plutôt comme ça que j'ai envie de
réfléchir
donc pour faire revenir du long terme
dans la façon dont on fonctionne
aujourd'hui
alors il ya quelques éléments un peu
pratique qui me paraissent pertinents à
ce titre le premier c'est de retrouver
une amélioration de retrouver un
dialogue de qualité entre la sphère
politique et la technostructure
aujourd'hui en gros le discours de la
sphère politique vis-à-vis de la
technostructure et de l'aider et de leur
dénier tout droit toute légitimité à la
co construction de l'avenir au motif
qu'ils n'ont pas été élus enfin vous
avez pas élu votre médecin si vous
choisissez les voulu dénier pas tout
droit pour construire votre avenir si
jamais il est votre bilan de santé donc
il ya un donc j'ai une qualité du
dialogue et les pays qui regarde un peu
plus à long terme sont des pays qui ont
une qualité de dialogue entre la
technostructure et le pouvoir politique
qui est meilleur par exemple les pays
nordiques
par exemple la grande bretagne sont des
pays dans lesquels la haie et même si on
n'est pas d'accord avec leur régime
politique par exemple chine la chine est
historiquement neydens et c'est un pays
d'ingénieurs la chine parce que
l'aristocratie chinoise il ya quelques
siècles c'était les ingénieurs
hydrauliciens il savait organisé
l'adduction d'eau pour faire fonctionner
les rivières c'est sale c'est ça la
caste et à l'autre extrémité du spectre
vous avez des états unis ou si vous êtes
ingénieur vous êtes un raté et si vous
êtes quelqu'un qui a réussi où vous êtes
avocat ou médecin et du reste comme ils
font pas d'ingénieur chez eux il est
important que chez les autres marchent
très bien
bon ben on a un peu trop tendance à
penser que c'est ça la ligne bleue des
vosges alors que je pense qu'on se
trompe et que le temps des gens qui
pensent le long terme
il est urgent de le faire revenir donc
les effets de manche on verra plus tard
le donc dans les dents les éléments qui
permettent de recruter du long terme et
à celui là il ya un deuxième élément qui
est de des finances y réaliser des
économies en gros quand vous avez ça je
connais bien parce que c'est des clients
la stratégie de long terme dans une
entreprise cotée en bourse c'est
n'importe quoi entre 6 mois et 3 ans en
fonction de la météo
c'est un peu court et on le voit bien
dans le domaine du changement climatique
en fait les gens avec lesquels on
travaille le plus facilement c'est les
gens qui par construction un pied dans
le temps long les gens qui gère les
infrastructures genre dans le monde
financier ceux qui sont bons ils y
racontent tous des carabistouilles par
rapport à ce qu'ils font vraiment mais
ceux qui ont j'ai envie de dire le plus
envie de faire des choses un peu
sérieuse souvent c'est des fonds de
pension situées dans des pays qui sont
favorables qui sont à l'aise avec le
avec le tendre donc c'est des fonds de
pension suédois anglais etc
c'est chez eux que vous allez trouver
les choses les plus intéressantes on va
dire le guardian par exemple à un fonds
de pension pour ces salariés est bien
connue dans la presse qui a une
politique sur le plan du climat qui est
assez agressive donc le dompter
financiarisé l'économie parce qu'on
pouvait dire ce qu'on voulait du
capitalisme familial
il a quand même une caractéristique que
je constate au sein de ma clientèle
c'est qu'il pense le temps long de façon
plus facile
un actionnaire familial il a moins peur
de se faire bouffer par les parties et
donc si le rendement de ces capitaux
investis est un peu plus bas il ya un
peu plus bas et puis voilà c'est pas
très grave donc donc il ya voilà il ya
des erreurs tout ça moi j'ai une vision
un peu à l'anglais c'est à dire qu'il
faut regarder marche après marche sur
l'escalier
je me méfie beaucoup des grands soirs
qui qui permettrait d'aller
instantanément du système imparfait vers
le système parfait
l'histoire montre que ça marche moyen
quand on essaye de faire comme ça oui
mais la question c'est de savoir d'abord
comment on gère en effet des politiques
qui se font ou doigt mouillé je pense à
la fermeture de fessenheim qui est un
truc décidé de façon purement
politicienne sur un coin de table pour
un accord pour un accord entre le ps et
les verts qui aboutit petit à petit à
des décisions qui engagent l'avenir du
pays donc première chose comment on gère
des politiques qui prennent ce genre d
idées des deux décisions sur lesquelles
on ne peut pas revenir
comment on fait ensuite pour penser le
mix énergétique français dans un cadre
où il est très difficile de faire valoir
que pour l'instant jusqu'à preuve du
contraire si on veut sortir des énergies
décarbonées les énergies renouvelables
ne vont pas suffire si on veut sortir
des énergies carbonées
oui carbone est pas là dessus alors
elles vont pas suffire ça dépend ce
qu'on veut en face il ya une blague que
je fais souvent dans mes conférences de
dire qu'un monde sans pensant
renouvelables ne pose aucun problème
à preuve c'est celui dans lequel
l'humanité a toujours vécu me bien sûr
un siècle voilà on est d'accord
donc ça derrière on choisit combien
d'énergie on consomme donc ça ne pose
strictement car voilà là où on peut
commencer à se gratter la tête c est ce
que c'est compatible 100% renouvelable
avec ce qu'aujourd'hui
mes chers compatriotes comme disait
l'autre considère comme étant le minimum
incompressible sur leur pouvoir d'achat
c'est vrai que les discussions
intéressantes commencer le sur ce point
sur sur la question de fessenheim
comment est-ce qu'on gère les politiques
il ya que deux manières de les gérer ce
que j'ai compris du fonctionnement du
monde politique
c'est qu'en fait le politique ne fait qu
arbitre et dépression il ne fait pas de
grands pans de grands plans par donc
bien pensé qui va chercher derrière aaa
à vendre on va dire on voit bien en fait
aujourd'hui le politique c'est
essentiellement une somme de
clientélisme électoraux malheureusement
c'est comme ça alors encore une fois les
bons auteurs vous expliquons que ça a
toujours été comme ça
et donc si en face on a une population
qui se soucient peu du sujet ou qui n'a
pas résolu ses propres contradictions
c'est plus difficile pour une politique
d'émerger qu'ils soient en cohérence
avec le problème à traiter
c'est comme ça donc on retombe sur le
rôle des médias parce que pour que les
gens comprennent de problèmes à traiter
il faut qu'à un moment quelqu'un leur a
expliqué la deuxième chose c'est que
on peut quand même leur demander un
effort qui est celui qui oserait
attenberg leur demande qui est au moins
de se documenter de lire un résumé pour
décideurs du giec ses trente pages même
si c'est des gens sur occupés 30 pages
ça prend une heure une heure et demie
deux heures parce que c'est une
littérature pas nécessairement très
accessible et très facile mais c'est
deux heures c'est pas deux ans donc on
pourrait leur demander ça maintenant il
n'ya pas d'examen de passage pour se
faire élire c'est comme ça c'est la
règle et c'est plutôt pas mal que ce
soit comme ça
sauf que du coup ça un inconvénient
c'est que ce fait réduire n'est jamais
une garantie compétences l'élection
n'est pas une garantie de compétence et
mais il ya que deux manières de s'en
sortir
ou bien la population résout ses propres
contradictions edit j'ai bien compris ce
que j'aurai ce que je n'aurais pas si on
veut aller dans cette direction et je
demande que ça soit fait ou bien alors
il ya plein de manières de faire il ya
des élections il ya déjà des des voix
intermédiaire j'ai envie de dire comme
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
qui est une tentative est quelque part
il faut quand même savoir gré à macron
d'avoir fait cette expérience même si on
vous la trouvez insatisfaisante
bon il l'a fait une expérience qu'il a
quand même qu'il avait lancé je suis pas
sûr qu'il savait exactement pourquoi il
est je suis pas sûr non plus qu'il avait
mesuré ce à quoi celle langage est la
preuve c'est quand même qui s'est
rétractée sur pas mal de choses telles
qu il s'est finalement rétracté en fait
la façon non il sait pas vraiment
rétracter au sens où il n'a pas compris
ce à quoi il s'engage et c'est plutôt
comme ça je veux que je te dire ça n'a
aucun sens sur un problème que vous avez
vous même pas compris parce que là je
peux le dire je pense qu'il n'a pas
compris le problème
ça n'a aucun sens sur un prime qu'il n'a
pas compris de demander à des gens qui
n'ont pas plus compris le problème au
moment où il démarre pas aujourd'hui
mais au bout il démarre de vous sortir
des propositions que vous vous engagez à
reprendre sans filtre dans un projet
lourd ça n'a aucun sens un exemple une
promesse de cette nature et je pense que
les gens qui au début ils ont cru et ne
devait pas être très nombreux bons donc
à la fin il y est arrivé ce qui devait
arriver c'est là qu'il n'a pas fait ce
qu'il aurait dû s'engager à faire et en
fait c'est ce que le haut conseil pour
le climat a relevé dans
un avis convient de rendre il ya
quelques quelques jours c'est que il
aurait dû adopter cette instance de
moyens d'évaluation permettant aux gens
de comprendre quelle était la portée des
propositions qu'il faisait au moment où
ils se disent nous les citoyens on est
d'accord pour interdire la pub pour les
grosses bagnoles qu' il soit avec des
gens en sachant faire des calculs ça
existe qui puisse leur dire voilà ce
genre de mesure on peut espérer en
retirer entre temps étant de baisses
d'émissions parent ou ça contribue à un
mouvement global
si on remplace des grosses voitures par
des petites voitures un nombre de
voiture égale voilà à peu près ce qu'on
va gagner et on peut considérer que la
pub c'est 10% blaney on aurait dû leur
adjoindre des gens qui aurait été
capable de leur dire voilà à peu près la
portée de ce que vous de ce que vous
décidez et comme on leur avait donné un
mandat qui étaient baissés devant les
émissions de 40% en 1990 et 2030
eh bien il aurait fait des additions et
puis à la fin ils auraient vu s'il était
dans les clous pas donc ça c'est la
première chose qui aurait dû être fait
et en face la seule chose que le seul
engagement que macro aura dû prendre
c'est celui de l'évaluation
donc il aurait dû dire je m'engage à
passer le temps nécessaire à regarder ce
que vous m'avez proposer et à vous faire
une réponse circonstanciée c'est à dire
je prends et si je prends pas je vous
dit pourquoi
à la limite vous avez le droit de me
répondre en expliquant que les arguments
sont bons ou pas bons mais en gros il
aurait dû s'engager à initier un
dialogue au bon niveau c'est à dire faut
par les faits et chiffres un moment là
ce qui s'est passé c'est que toute cette
étape-là a été bâclée donc on s'est dit
tout ça est une grande bataille d'idées
de slogans de grand problème c'est pas
du tout une bataille d'idées et devance
les deux slogans c'est une bataille de
trucs très pratique si vous avez un gain
qui font rien à l'école vous avez des
problèmes très pratique sur les rangs
comment lui donner envie comme ça c'est
pas de théorie très pratiquement voilà
c'est exactement pareil on a on avait
des problèmes très pratique
à gérer et ils n'ont pas été gérée alors
sa demande est à la fois des compétences
côté convention citoyenne et sa demande
des compétences du côté de
l'administration parce que le koala
l'administration on a le plus souvent
pas non plus les compétences pour
traiter ce genre de problèmes en
particulier par à bercy est ce que parce
que là ce que ce que vous esquissez
c'est la question de savoir commun en
fait on répond à cet enjeu majeur qui
est celui du changement climatique
sauf que il me semble que je suis
d'accord avec vous qu'il faut d'une
raisonnement chiffres et des choses
extrêmement concrètes
en même temps ces choses concrètes
est-ce qu'elles ne dépassent pas la pure
question des émissions de carbone et de
ce qu'on appelle généralement le climat
je m'explique j'ai tendance à penser que
a focalisé sur le climat et les
émissions de carbone
en fait on ne pense le problème que de
que en partie c'est à dire dans la
partie chiffrables
cela dit le reste on peut le chiffrer
mais on oublie toujours je pense que
aujourd'hui prendre en compte les
bouleversements climatiques prendre en
compte l'impact de l'être humain sur la
planète ça ne se fait pas seulement à
travers les émissions de carbone qui
peuvent aboutir à se revendre des droits
à polluer des droits des droits carbone
qu'il faut prendre en compte l'ensemble
des modes de vie à travers
l'artificialisation des sols à travers
la destruction des écosystèmes marins à
travers le l'érosion des sols parce
qu'ils ne sont pas entretenu parce
qu'ils ne sont pas travailler donc les
techniques agricoles
or j'ai l'impression tout ce pan là en
fait tu disparais pourquoi parce que là
ça implique des changements dans les
tout simplement l'organisation complète
des sociétés
je veux dire le mur bannissent mlle la
façon dont on implante économiquement du
travail plus ou moins proche des gens et
c'est là ça devient en fait ça oblige un
changement beaucoup plus brutale oui et
non en fait quand on regarde les
émissions de co2 les émissions de co2
c'est notamment la contrepartie de
l'utilisation de l'énergie et
l'utilisation de l'énergie en fait c'est
pareil un peu abstrait quand on dit ça
mais en fait ça a un côté très concret
c'est l'utilisation des machines
l'énergie ces machines
c'est votre voiture qui consomme du
pétrole c'est pas vous c'est votre
machine à laver qui consomment de
l'électricité c'est pas vous c'est votre
frigo qui concept de l'électorat ce qui
a remplacé la force humaine et la force
animale
absolument c'est donc en fait consommer
de plus en plus d'énergie c'est juste
maîtriser une flotte de machines de plus
en plus importante et ça veut dire qu'on
est capable de créer des flux puisque
d'énergie c'est les flux de plus en plus
important on peut transformer de plus en
plus de minerai de fer tout un tas
d'objets en acier on peut transformer de
plus en plus de pétrole en tout un tas
d'objets en plastique on peut mettre en
mouvement des masses toujours plus
importantes et jusqu'à aller passer son
week-end sur eux mars quand on s'appelle
elon musk et c'est donc en fait
augmenter la quantité d'énergie qu'on
utilise c'est juste augmenter les flux
de transformation sur terre c'est ça que
ça veut dire
alors ça nous a apporté des bienfaits à
court terme parce que tous les objets
que vous avez dans cette pièce tous les
objets que vous avez chez vous tous les
objets vous avez au travail tous les
objets que vous verrez dans la rue
samedi que des ressources transformé par
notre activité s'est dit que ça donc
plus on a d'énergie plus on peut
transformer tout ce qui nous tombe sous
la main dans la nature et en faire autre
chose y compris des sardines en boîte de
sardines alors la limite à cette affaire
là c'est évidemment que si vous piochez
trop de ressources dans la nature à un
moment elle se renouvelle pas où elle ne
se renouvelait jamais tant qu'il en
reste - et puis vous faites apparaître
tout un tas de nuisance qui sont les
sous produits indésirables de votre
activité qu'on appelle la pollution donc
plus plus plus à s'agiter plus ça fume
j'ai envie de dire et puis ça fait des
trous partout alors l'énergie
al'avantage dans cette affaire-là d'être
un proxy un marqueur de la totalité de
nuisance puisque l'essentiel de
nuisances sont quantitativement une
contrepartie de notre activité en volume
plus on crée de bâtiments plus on va
artificialisés de sol mais par ailleurs
plus on a besoin d'énergie pour faire du
ciment et de l'acier donc si vous
regardez l'énergie avec un tout petit
peu de hauteur de vue en fait vous vous
rendez compte que derrière vous à les
capturer tout un tas d'autres nuisances
dont il faut également s'occuper
c'est absolument évident la perte de
biodiversité l'artificialisation des
sols et l'érosion des sols
là où on peut avoir un problème si on
est focalisé sur la partie climat c'est
que dans les solutions au changement
climatique
certaines peuvent augmenter la pression
dans d'autres compartiments alors je
vais en prendre je prendre un exemple
c'est la biomasse j'ai vraiment tout ce
qui pousse
partie des gens pensent qu'on va pouvoir
remplacer le pétrole par des arts au
carburant moi j'espère tellement
biocarburants parce que bio cbo
conférence pas très bien ou alors les
agrocarburants en pratique c'est quoi
ces du blé que vous transformez en
éthanol les maïs que vous transformez en
éthanol l'éthanol ça brûle ça en place
les sens c'est du tournesol ou du saut
ou du colza que vous transformez en
diesel ça brûle pareil c'est
éventuellement du bois que vous
transformez directement en combustible
pour faire tourner une centrale
électrique etc l'huile de palme qu'on
importe maintenant en europe pour faire
du bio diesel
alors en fait toutes ces cultures elles
ont besoin d espace et cet espace vous
allez prendre soin sur les cultures
alimentaires ce que vous ne faites pas
parce que la population augmente soit
sur les écosystèmes dont une partie de
la course vers les biocarburants
engendre de la déforestation ce qu'ils
vont au brésil vont quêter à son majeur
alors si j'ai aussi pour nourrir nos
vaches au président mais oui aussi là
auquel cas ça sert à quoi le problème
plutôt que de le baisser parce que la
solution est encore pire que le premier
donc avec une bonne comptabilité carbone
vous voyez quand même arriver ce genre
de truc est normalement si vraiment vous
êtes soucieux de résoudre le problème
vous le faites pas mais si vous le
faites pas ça veut dire que du coup vous
devez vous tourner vers d'autres marge
de manoeuvre est typiquement pour les
voitures ça serait beaucoup plus simple
de diviser le poids des voitures ont
conduit par deux et de les limiter à 110
105 jours des voitures ça consommerait
deux fois moins de pétrole et donc on
n'aurait pas besoin des biocarburants
pour diviser la consommation de pétrole
par deux donc là donc les effets de bord
sur un certain nombre de solutions entre
guillemets au changement climatique
peuvent être délétères sur d'autres
pressions environnementales
vous avez un autre sujet qui est la
consommation des espaces qui est demandé
par le solaire l'énergie solaire
photovoltaïque à quantité d'électricité
égal il faut 1000 fois plus d'espacé
pour faire de l'électricité avec du
solaire qu'avec du nucléaire donc si
vous voulez remplacer en france qu' un
certain nombre de gens qui pensent que
c'est une bonne idée
le nucléaire par le solaire c'est pas
mon idée moi je trouve que c'est une
très mauvaise idée mais qu'un certain
nombre de gens qui pensent que c'est une
bonne idée fakih ce ce que c'est
souhaitable jeu parce qu'ils savent que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
mais qu'ils ont fait c'est souhaitable
eh bien il faut multiplier par 1000
l'espace occupé par les centrales
nucléaires et faire ça en panneaux
solaires et on recommence à voir arriver
des projets dans lesquels on veut couper
des morceaux de forêt pour m'aider
soler d'une très mauvaise idée à tout
point de vue pour la biodiversité pour
le climat pour tout ce qu'on veut femme
pratiquée que les éoliennes alors les
éoliennes aussi on commence à en planter
de plus en plus et on est encore très
très loin du compte si on veut faire les
50% du clean exactement qui était dans
l'accord programmatique vers ps nous
faut encore les x 3 4 les éoliennes
existantes
donc on n'a pas fini on n'a pas fini de
voir le bout c'est toute la question
c'est de savoir si on veut préserver
dans la préservation la lutte pour le
préserver le climat
on doit pas aussi prendre en compte la
préservation d'un tout petit peu
d'espacés naturels qui ne soit pas
transformé par l'homme vous parliez de
l'impact de l'homme si on veut avoir du
solaire et de l'éolien partout ça veut
dire qu'il n'y aura plus un seul paysage
ou une portera son regard en se disant
que l'homme n'y a pas mis sa main rien
que ça ça après ce n'est pas comptable
milan séances 14 france il déjà le cas
mais disons qu'il ya des transformations
paysagère qui sont plus artificialisés à
la autres donc quand on a une forêt
plantée comme dans les landes où quand
même en dessous il ya de la boue c'est
quelques champignons à ramasser ça fait
moins artificiel que monaco en béton on
est bien d'accord mais donc pour en
revenir à la question à la question de
l'occupation de l'espace vous avez un
une commission qui a été du ministère de
l'environnement qui rend des avis tous
les mois sur les projets éoliens et
solaires qui demande une dérogation pour
pouvoir s'implanter parce que il empiète
sur une zone où il ya des espèces
protégées ou etc
il ya deux trois avis qui sont entre 1
et 3 avril qui sont rendus tous les mois
sur des comme ça des projets qui doit
une dérogation la vie est
systématiquement négatif pour bien seul
avis positif depuis que je regarde ça
depuis un an donc oui il ya un impact
sur la biodiversité de ces installations
renouvelables au sol donc voilà donc
c'est donc il faut choisir le moindre
inconvénient en fait c'est ça le sessad
dans les moindres dans le moindre
inconvénient il va falloir qu'on fasse
un arbitrage entre arrêter d'en vouloir
toujours plus parce que ça fait partie
du jeu et accepter la mise au régime
le les solutions qui sont j'ai envie de
dire les plus compact possible et le
nucléaire a cet avantage d'être très
compacte parce que il utilise très peu
de matière pour produire beaucoup
d'énergie
donc du coup il n'a pas besoin de
beaucoup d espace il a une vraie il
exploite une réaction qui est très très
énergiques
donc du coup faut mettre plein de béton
ou là où il est l'histoire ne prendrait
pas dans le bas côté mais c'est juste là
où il est et puis comme il utilise très
peu de matière il fait aussi très peu de
déchets donc ces déchets sont des
cochonneries
mais il y en a très très peu on a on a
un il ya un ordre de grandeur qui est
peu connu dans ce pays
mais la totalité des déchets emmerdant
j'ai envie de dire ce qu'ils sont à
longue durée de vie et à haute activité
qu'on a créé depuis le début du parc
nucléaire français
depuis quelques dizaines d'années occupe
le volume d'un gymnase donc oui c'est
très emmerdant mais si le volume
naginata en france un pas monstrueux en
termes de volumes s'est réparti sur
trois pc alors c'est un ses réparties
sur trois sites d'entreposage le
principal est halal parce qu'il ya tout
un mythe autour des déchets nucléaires
souvent l'argument des antinucléaires
s'étaient dit oui il ya des déchets
nucléaires on sait pas comment faire
ils peuvent nous exploser au visage à
tout moment or alors ça n'explose pas et
on sait très bien quoi en faire
simplement la solution qui est proposé
pour ne plus en entendre parler est une
solution dont les mêmes qui disent on
sait pas quoi en faire
iliad annonce a quand même on veut pas
s'il s'agit tout simplement les mettre
dans un trou il ya une anecdote que
j'aime bien cité en ce qui concerne les
déchets nucléaires c'est qu'il ya deux
milliards d'années
il ya des réacteurs il ya des réacteurs
nucléaires naturel qui se sont formés au
gabon et au clos dans une
un endroit qui est encore une mine
d'uranium lanfang millionième abandonné
aujourd'hui et ses réacteurs naturelles
ont fait des déchets nucléaires naturel
puisque il avait même été prédit par la
théorie avant d'avoir été découvert
s'est expliqué en quoi ces rectangles
naturel commence en fait ils on s'est un
peu compliqué à expliquer le au sein de
l'uranium
il ya deux est ce qu'on appelle deux
isotopes ce qui définit un élément par
exemple le faire le chrome ou le carbone
c'est le nombre de protons l'uranium à
92 protons mais il peut avoir un nombre
de neutrons mais neutre on sait des
particules neutres mais qui font de la
masse qui rajoute du poids qui varie
donc dans l'uranium 235 qui à 235
nucléons au total et là dedans vous avez
92 proton et le reste donc 235 -92 ce
qu'il doit faire 143 on n'a pas neutre
et puis vous avez un autre isotope une
autre variété on va dire comme une
aubergine qui est pas de la même couleur
mais c'est toujours une aubergine c'est
un groupe de bergers qui élit l'uranium
238 donc il a toujours le même nombre de
protons à 3 12 mai il a 146 à neutre ils
n'ont pas les mêmes propriétés physiques
en particulier d'uranium 235 quand vous
lui envoyez un neutron à la bonne
vitesse
il va l'avaler et se casser en deux il
va avoir une indigestion la explosé et
s'est cassé en deux c'est ça la fission
si vous prenez un noyau d'uranium 238
voulons envoyer un autre on dessus ils
se cassent pas il n'a pas envie il à
l'absorber puisse transformer plutonium
mais il n'a pas il va pas se casser en
deux donc le l'isotope qu'on exploite
dans nos réacteurs nucléaires celui qui
nous donne de l'énergie ses 235
il se trouve qu'il vaut 0 7 % de
l'uranium actuelle mais il se désintègre
au cours du temps cet uranium 235 très
lentement
il faut 700 millions d'années pour que
la moitié disparaissent et donc il ya
deux milliards d'années sa concentration
dans l'uranium ce n'est pas zéro 7 %
c'était 3 s'était ouvert autour de 3%
c'est-à-dire la concentration en uranium
235 qu'on a aujourd'hui dans les
réacteurs après enrichissement
quand on commence à exploiter d'uranium
donc il y aura des hommes étaient
naturellement enrichis on va dire
il ya deux milliards d'années dans les
gisements d'uranium et puis il ya eu des
infiltrations d'eau dans cette mine est
en fait on a besoin de l'eau pour que la
réaction se déclenche
c'est avec linky de centrales nucléaires
voilà donc ça a créé une petite centrale
nucléaire souterraine qui s'est mise à
fonctionner alors quand ça chauffait
trop parce qu'il y avait trop de fission
et l'eau s'évaporer
et puis d'autres donc ça s'arrêtait on a
besoin de l'eau puis laure venel sarkozy
s'est appuyé et c'est donc ça a
fonctionné malgré un pull c'est comme ça
pendant des centaines de milliers
d'années et ça a fait des déchets et les
alors ces déchets ont disparu depuis
longtemps parce que l'idée intérieur
aussi au cours du temps mais les
descendants de ces déchets qui eux sont
stables sont à l'endroit où les déchets
ont été formés donc en fait les déchets
s'est décomposé solide pour l'essentiel
enfin une fois qu'ils sont dans le vert
s'est décomposé solide ça bouge pas donc
c'est des cailloux emmerdant mais c'est
donc vous connaissez à 400 m sous terre
dans une couche géologique qui a des
dizaines de millions d'années et qui
sera encore là leur plume à need et aura
disparu depuis longtemps et vous les
oublier on a sur terre la surface des
problèmes à des merdes à bhl sur les
bras en ce moment qui s'appelle
l'érosion de la biodiversité la perte de
sol les phytosanitaires le changement
climatique les déstabilisations j'ai
touché du client est ce que vous
expliquez c'est que de toute façon si on
ne s'accorde pas à utiliser le nucléaire
avec le réchauffement climatique dans
son temps l'inter sera même plus vivable
non mais elle est déjà plus vivable pour
une partie des petites parties
l'humanité aujourd'hui c'est la fraction
des gens pour qui la terre sera de moins
en moins 10 heures ce qui va augmenter
c'est comme ça que ça va se passer dans
un siècle il restera toujours désordre
vous savez on a eu une espèce totalement
ubiquiste à l'école bord pionsat c'est
la chanson s'accroche absolument partout
donc je n'ai strictement aucune angoisse
sur le devenir de l'humanité
on vient d'une espèce qui à un moment
n'avait que quelques millions de
représentants sur terre si on retourne à
quelques millions de représentants sur
terre on survit en tant qu'espèce alors
qu'un problème c'est tout le problème
c'est tout le problème voilà deux des
individus et de l'est de la possibilité
de vivre décemment de la questure il pas
les bonnes questions en question c'est
est ce que tu sais quoi le nombre
d'individus mais la masse à travers et
dans quelles conditions
et là effectivement avec quelques degrés
de réchauffement en un siècle
ça sera pas le nombre d'individus qu'on
a aujourd'hui et ça sera pas les
conditions aujourd'hui justement
vos conférences notamment sa science po
vous expliquer longuement à l'aide de
graphiques avec d'autres cartes
ce à quoi pourrait ressembler le monde
l'europe notamment si on fait rien si on
n'arrive pas baisser notre des émissions
de gaz à effet serre alors je vous
laisse vous expliquer si nous n'agissons
pas dans 60 70 ans entend à quoi
ressemblera l'europe
je crois comme dès l'automne il sera à
peu près le pôle nord ah non pas le pôle
nord non
le pôle nord il ya peu par refroidir le
climat dans le cadre du réchauffement
climatique
par contre il peut y avoir des
incursions d'air polaire de temps en
temps comme ce qui vient de se passer au
texas mais c'est pas dire que cette pôle
nord c'est alors la première chose qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est que si on ne
fait rien les émissions n'augmente pas
indéfiniment jusqu'à la fin du siècle
parce qu'en fait la quantité de pétrole
de gaz et de charbon qui reste sous
terre n'est pas suffisante pour que on
en brûle de plus en plus tous les ans
jusqu'à la fin du siècle
en fait en ce qui concerne la quantité
de pétrole qui reste sous terre on est
déjà en train d'en brûler doit enfin en
ce qui concerne le pétrole on est déjà
en train de brûler de moins en moins
depuis 2008 sur terre sur la partie
pétrole conventionnel sert la quantité
de pétrole conventionnel ce qui n'est
pas le pétrole de schiste états unis et
ce qui n'est pas les sables bitumineux
du canada
on est passé par un maximum dans le
monde en 2008 à cause de la limitation
des gisements qu' il faut 50 à 400
millions d'années pour faire du pétrole
et donc quand y en a plus le pétrole de
schiste et les sables bitumineux sont
des industries qui sont beaucoup plus
capitalistiques que le pétrole ordinaire
avec des rendements d'extraction qui
sont bien moins bon
le pétrole de schiste aux états unis
n'avaient jamais gagné d'argent depuis
la création de cette industrie sauf en
2020 parce que la production s'est cassé
la gueule parce qu'on arrêtait
d'investir
donc c'est assez marrant c'est une
industrie qui ne peut gagner de l'argent
que quand on arrête d'investir avec la
production baisse est en fait il n'est
pas du tout impossible que le tout
pétrole confondues on est passé le
maximum en 2019
même en 2018 pour être précis en tout
cas si on l'a pas passer ce maximum il
ya deux ans il est pourtant vraiment pas
longtemps ça veut dire que même si on
veut émettre de plus en plus de co2 au
titre du pétrole
on pourra pas ce qui aura de moins en
moins de pétrole et même si
l'automobiliste français a dit je veux
pas peut-être qu'il veut pas mais c'est
quand même comme ça que sa présence sera
rationnée qu'on le veuille ou non de
toute façon il y en aura - donc il ya de
toute façon une limitation qui va
s'exercer par les prix par les volumes
par un mélange des deux par jean sérien
par une baisse de la population je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas on pensait
avoir vendu pétrole pareil pour le gaz
avec une dizaine d'années décalage
c'est à dire que même si on veut de plus
en plus de gaz et pas d'ici 2030 2035
n'aura pas de plus en plus en le charbon
c'est un peu moins évident il est
possible car et pour encore assez
longtemps en quantité croissante
mais à partir du moment où vous avez
moins en moins de pétrole vous avez
moins en moins de transports et
l'économie globale se grippe
même si vous avez encore au charbon et
gaz donc ce qui est vraisemblable de mon
point de vue c'est que en politique de
laisser faire vous n'allez pas avoir une
économie qui se porte de mieux en mieux
des émissions qui croise de plus en plus
jusqu'à la fin du siècle avec un enfer
environnementale en fait vous allez
avoir la conjonction des deux
emmerdements c'est à dire à la fois
l'enfer environnementale au titre des
émissions passées parce que vous avez
une inertie très très forte
on entre les émissions et le changement
que ça induit en gros le changement
induit par les émissions passées dur des
milliers d'années d'accord après le tir
de change et non même si on change
maintenant de toute façon pendant des
milliers d'années le climat va encore
dérivés d'accord on peut on pas pu
l'éviter
donc vous allez avoir
le bazar environnementale est de moins
en moins de co2 à un moment de toute
façon mais ce qui veut dire aussi si
vous avez moins en moins de co2 c'est à
dire que vous avez moins en moins de
machines donc de moins en moins de
maîtrise de votre environnement donc de
moins en moins de capacité à faire face
à l'adversité c'est beaucoup plus facile
de monter des digues en une année quand
vous avez des tractopelles et du béton
que quand vous avez des pelles des
pioches et les gens donc l'exosquelette
qu'on a constitué avec les combustibles
fossiles et l'énergie abondante à mesure
qu'il baissera qu'il se contractera nous
aurons par ailleurs des emmerdements
environnementaux qui vont augmenter donc
la politique du laisser faire c'est
cette taille qui se referme
j'ai envie de dire de façon non gérés et
cruel la politique de l'action est une
politique dans laquelle de toute façon
il faut qu'on accepte une forme de mise
origine
alors c'est très compliqué c'est très
dur c'est un énorme défi pour le moment
très peu de gens travaillent sur la
façon de résoudre ce défi donc un des
besoins urgents qu'on a aussi c'est du
jus de cerveau pour voir comment est ce
qu'on arrive à attaquer ce problème là
et il suffit pas de dire je veux pas
pour pas les voir d'ailleurs je veux pas
moi je pourrais dire je veux pas
vieillir c'est pas ça qui va dire donc
le je veux pas n'est pas une réponse
appropriée
il faut regarder et voir comment comment
on avance mais encore une fois j'insiste
sur un point le laisser-faire n'est pas
la garantie d'un soutien ans depuis le
début de notre discussion il ya un
élément que vous mettez en avant
plusieurs fois c'est la question de la
publicité du rôle de la publicité j'ai
tendance à penser pour ma part qu'il ya
deux sources de pollution majeure sur la
planète actuellement c'est la publicité
et la démographie via la publicité parce
que c'est à la base de cette
surconsommation qui nécessite de
produire en permanence et qui induit
cette cette société entièrement fondée
sur l'idée qu'il faut augmenter les
biens de consommation et que c'est ça
qui apporterait le bien-être dont pour
s'aperçoit pourtant que c'est totalement
faux en tout cas ça n'apporte pas le
bonheur collectif ça c'est très clair ni
même individuelle et la démographie
parce que de toute façon dans une avec
des ressources limitées quoi qu'il
arrive si on veut que les êtres humains
qui sont là vivent à peu près dé sa main
ce n'est pas tenable et la question de
la façon dont on nous
les êtres humains se pose ce que vous
partagez ça parce que je suis depuis
tout à l'heure la question de la
publicité revient assez souvent dans
votre or la publicité je sais pas où est
la poule et wolof
mais je ne sais pas s'il ya de la
publicité et pc pour ça qu'on se
gobergent ou si c'est parce qu'on aime
se goberger qu'il ya un public pour la
publicité
voilà je pense qu'il ya un peu des deux
en tout cas ce dont je suis sûr c'est
que si j'étais aux manettes
je n'aurais pas beaucoup de scrupules
interdire la publicité dans un certain
nombre de domaines
voilà je ça me gênerait pas plus que ça
d'avoir à le faire je sais pas si ça
vaut rien n'est fait majeur mais en tout
cas ça me gêne pas plus que ça en ce qui
concerne la démographie alors il est
évident que toutes choses égales par
ailleurs
plus on est nombreux et plus on exerce
une pression importante
on est bien d'accord il ya dans les
années 70 au moment où sont nés beaucoup
beaucoup de mouvements environnementaux
et de réflexion environnementale majeure
dans les grandes organisations dans les
grandes organisations non
gouvernementales environnementales
actuelles
beaucoup sont nés dans les années 70
greenpeace les amis de la terre le vvf
est né dans les airs à la fin des années
60 les années 70 c'est aussi l'année du
club de rome
enfin le début des années 70 cela des
travaux du light illusion limite à la
croissance et c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose
les gens disent que c'est parce qu'on a
vu la terre de l'espace grâce à apollo
et qu'on s'est rendu compte que c'était
un espace physique ce petit jeu c'est
pas tout cas il ya une
il ya aussi eu beaucoup de réflexions à
ce moment là sur la surpopulation qui
sont arrivés sur la table dont un livre
qui avait été écrit à peu près dans
cette époque là qui s'appelait la bombe
b et qui disait que on risquait la
surpopulation alors aujourd'hui on
n'arrive plus on l'a fait je pense que
malheureusement oui j'ai le terme mais
le fusain est encore quasiment une
excuse assume en quoi c'est un crime
d'être même soutien je suis père de deux
enfants est donc logique et contribuer
comme tout le monde mais le fait est que
on est aujourd'hui malheureusement trop
nombreux sur terre pour que ça on puisse
être dans un état stable c'est à dire
que 8 milliards de terriens
au surplus aspirants tous à vivre comme
des classes moyennes occidentales
c'est sûr que ça passe pas ça marche pas
donc à un moment le système se régule
donc on sera moins 10 milliards on vivra
pas comme des occidentaux où les deux
roues il ya des épidémies c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui est alors le lait
doit formuler régulation alors les modes
de régulation de la population c'est
bien simple il y en a enfin les voies de
régulation rapide il y en a que deux
c'est les famines et des épidémies et
les épidémies ça va encore plus vite que
les famines là les famines de l'ancien
temps quand on regarde des morts par
famine en europe il ya quelques siècles
les grandes années de disette on pouvait
faire quelques millions de morts en
france
quant à peste noire est arrivée à la
tuer la moitié de la population donc en
quelques années donc les familles enfin
les épidémies effectivement c'est le
truc le plus rapide pour réguler les
populations
et comme l'homme n'a plus de prédateurs
macroscopique
tigre à dents de sabre qu'il va arriver
demain matin et manger 3 milliards
d'hommes et que c'est peu probable que
ce soient les martiens ou les jupitérien
jeu pourquoi qui s'en charge et bien de
fait s'il doit y avoir une régulation
rapidement vraisemblablement les petites
bêtes qui vont s'en charger il ya çà et
la famine alors la guerre est pas un
régulateur fort des populations c'est un
certain c'est quelque chose qui
favorisent souvent la famine et la
maladie ça ça favorise des mauvaises
conditions d'hygiène les mauvaises
conditions la grippe espagnole par
exemple les choses comme ça c'est pas si
c'est une conséquence directe de la
première guerre disons que ça affaiblit
les populations et ça permet de lier du
cadre mais son intégration sans plus
faible c'est clair que les maladies se
propagent beaucoup plus facilement donc
le le fait de ne pas gérer de nous mêmes
encore une fois comme on peut et de la
façon la plus pacifique possible
la taille de la population augmente
à l'évidence le risque que ça nous
arrive dessus d'une façon plus
désagréable malheureusement c'est c'est
désagréable à dire alors c'est toujours
très difficile de parler des sujets
démographique c'est des sujets qui nous
touchent aux tripes je vire se
reproduire et quand même un truc qui est
à la base du code génétique de toutes
espèces animales c'est c'est du reste
probablement pour cette raison très
profondément ancré dans toutes les
pensées religieuses
c'est très profondément ancré dans
énormément de règles de morale préserver
à tout prix la vie d'autrui et c'est
donc du fait de ce fait pardon ça rend
particulièrement difficile débat sur la
démographie c'est des choses qui sont si
compliqué d'en discuter en en ayant
l'air d'avoir toute sa tête j'ai envie
de dire c'est des sujets difficiles et
douloureux il n'empêche qu'il ya quand
même à mon avis des choses qu'on peut
faire et je vais mettre dans les pas
d'un père jésuite s'appelle gaye girons
qui avait dit quand il était chef
économiste de l'afd que toute l'aide au
développement française devrait être
concentrée sur trois éléments et 3
seulement qui sont l'éducation est ce
que les anglais appellent l'empowerment
je connais pas bien le français mais pas
véritablement d'équivalent femmes c'est
l'émancipation c'est serait peut-être le
terme le plus intéressant émancipation
je trouve est un terme un peu réducteur
ça désigne pas le partage du pouvoir ça
désigne un truc est plutôt se sortir des
griffes mais pas trop gérer en commun
voilà donc en pas vraiment pour moi
c'est plutôt géré en commun des femmes
parce qu'on constate que dès que les
femmes sont libres de leurs mouvements
elles ont envie de faire mal enfants et
c'est particulièrement important dans
les pays qui aujourd'hui ont des
natalités très galopante mais le
nigérian qui à l'évidence les gens qui
naissent aujourd'hui l'essentiel d'entre
eux sont voués à avoir une existence pas
très drôle le deuxième sujet c'est tous
les régimes de solidarité parce qu'il ya
énormément de pays
yann arthus-bertrand le rappelait encore
dans une interview récente ou comme n'y
a pas de système
étatiques ou la bâtisse est collectif de
solidarité va vous comptez sur vos
enfants et donc vous en faites plein en
interne ça si je suis malade si je suis
vieux et c'est un qui va s'occuper moi
donc ça c'est des mesures qui sont des
mesures
et puis évidemment dans la mesure où la
morale et les schémas culturels locaux
le permettent l'accès aux moyens de
contraception mais qui va qui va quand
même beaucoup avec les histoires de
dopage mais bien sûr question mais
devant on voit bien que l'éducation des
filles est un élément essentiel de
modification de société alors moi je
suis tu je suis très confortable avec
bien qu'étant un homme je suis sûre et
confortable avec avec ses suggestions et
je pense qu'effectivement si on veut
faire du bien à la planète c'est plus
important de faire ça que d'aider les
pays en question à se construire jeu
pourquoi un aéroport ou même un certain
nombre de bâtiments ou leur industrie
touristique ou qui en plus avec le moins
d'avions ça sera plus compliqué que vous
prenez un rebrousse poil tout les
indiens la pensée commune sur l'aide au
développement mais il ya aussi des
questions à se poser chez nous alors
j'avais beaucoup choqué il ya un an et
demi
parce que dans une interview dans social
terre j'avais dit se pose la question
dans les pays occidentaux de savoir
jusqu'où est ce qu'on doit dépenser des
moyens sans limite pour faire survivre
des gens en fin de vie qui sont pas en
bon état et qui en plus souvent n'ont
pas envie eux mêmes le problème enfin le
débat a ressurgi de façon cruciale dans
le traitement de la crise du coronavirus
week-end qui est une mesure
de fait même si c'est désagréable de
dire ça trop vieux et antigone de fait
c'est comme ça qu'on joue avec des
politiques de vaccination de personnes
parfois de très âgées qui est d'ailleurs
on voit l'état de l'insee qui montre non
pour un bus large que ça c'est à dire
mon propos est de dire en fait pour
préserver des gens qui étaient pour
l'essentiel en fin de vie oui qui on a
très fortement
j'aimerais dire obérer le confort et la
vie futur parce que les gosses qui sont
pas les gosses les milieux défavorisés
qui sont pas allés à l'école
oui ça se paiera dans 20 ans ils vont
ils vont s'en relever où ils vont pas
s'en relever les étudiants à qui on a
entre guillemets de voler une partie
très insouciante de leur vie enfin on a
tous été étudiant 80 % d'une classe
d'âge des noms c'est quand même le
souvenir de l'accès à une forme de vie
d'adulte sympathique et c'est une
parenthèse plutôt agréable entre la fin
de l'adolescence ou quand même on a
envie de pousser ses parents du coude et
les contraintes du début d'une vie
d'adulte ou faut gagner sa croûte c'est
enfin voila c'est une parenthèse qui est
quand même une parenthèse j'ai pas envie
de dire béni mais agréable c'est une
phase importante de la vie sociale des
jeunes adultes c'est à la trappe
aujourd'hui il passe six ans par jour
derrière un écran
voyons voir plus et je pense qu'il ya
une partie qui sont en train de devenir
neurasthénique on a quand même une
pauvre actions significatives d'une
classe d'âge arrivant sur le marché du
travail qui a pas trouvé de boulot
donc je suis pas en train de dire qu'on
ne devait pas ses placements bien
entendu mon nom je suis juste en train
de dire que l'arbitrage de fait ce que
nous avons fait c'est que nous avons
pris des mesures nous collectivement
puisque l'état c'est moi comme disait
l'autre
nous avons collectivement pris des
mesures qui arbitre en faveur d'une
classe d'âge est en défaveur d'une autre
voilà c'est un c'est un état de fait est
la question que je me pose c'est est-ce
que c'est très compatible avec les défis
qui nous attendent et mêmes est ce que
c'est le même arthus-bertrand disait
dans la même interview
est-ce qu'on lui pose la question est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à donner votre
vaccin à un jeune exilé oui sans
problème
moi j'en ai déjà profité alors je ne
sais pas s'il le pense vraiment je pense
que oui enfin je pense qu'une partie des
gens très âgés aujourd'hui quelque part
eux-mêmes
faudrait il faudrait leur demander oui
ils sont que cela donnera l'attendait
avec l'idée que on est en train de
sacrifier les jeunes pour peut-être
qu'une partie d'irène com com com
peuvent dire un certain nombre de grands
parents ben non en fait c'est pas tout
non c'est pas pour moi la priorité c'est
pour eux donc le et on a un rapport à la
mort aujourd'hui qui est devenu très
différent de ce qu'il était avant parce
que ça moi je me rappelle quand quand
j'étais jeune il y avait une expression
qui s'appelait mourir de vieillesse et
s'était même je me rappelle très bien de
mon père disant ça c'était mourir de sa
belle mort
bien sûr et d elles sont froides
s'appelle bord il y avait une belle
manière de mourir
d'abord la mort était légitime et
ensuite la belle manière de mourir c'est
pour les vieux et fatigué avec l'habile
plus l'idéal c'était comme le général de
gaulle l'avait nouvel arrivant génial
puis on peut dire que lui il a quand
même pas eu une vie où il s'est ennuyé
donc le cd sort aujourd'hui ça n'existe
plus mourir de sa belle mort vous êtes
toutes les morts une cause technique et
une cause technique ce qui sous-entend
dont on aurait besoin éviter c'est
absolument donc aller vite donc elle est
évitable et donc on a on a développé un
rapport à la mort qui est toute marron
il légitime parce que toute mort est
évitable
alors je pense que ce débat là qui est
aussi un débat difficile on le voit bien
ça nourrit des débats passionnés mon
sentiment c'est que pour difficile que
soient ces débats l'existence nous sera
rendue encore plus difficile si on
refuse de les avoir c'est un peu ma
conclusion alors c'est clair que c'est
entre deux maux il n'y a pas de solution
idéale dans cette affaire il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas une voie totalement
insouciante où on peut se dire voilà on
entend les sons les médecins faire et
puis surtout qu'est ce qu'il raconte
laventie quand même pas commencé à
s'occuper de ses problèmes qui sont
vraiment des bâton merdeux et de fait
c'est un peu des bâton merdeux
mais voilà je pense que quand même il
faut y entrer parce que ne pas le faire
ne coûtera entre guillemets plus cher en
terme en termes de confort que de faire
je pense que en effet ça peut nous
pouvons conclure sur cette idée que
lille ne peut que y avoir des débats
essentiels sinon que nous allons vers le
pire est que c'est peut-être pas pris
avoir le courage géant vient dire j'ai
envie de dire qu'aujourd'hui moi ce que
j'attends d'eux de la classe politique
puisque on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est peut-être pas des décisions qui
tourne nécessairement les bonnes par
contre j'attends d'eux du courage le
courage d'affronter le monde tel qu'il
est et non pas tel qu'ils avaient le
vendre eh bien merci j'ai un mac gens se
disent il y en aurait pu continuer cette
discussion pendant de longues minutes
merci merci beaucoup